each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
you
Fetzer and when the program managers and
our external relations group and this
panel discussion today I want to be
congratulated on picking such a narrow
topic this is probably about a broader
topic as as one can imagine but we were
but everything is sort of on the table
here I think you don't hear some really
interesting views and I'd really like to
encourage each of you at the very end to
answer to to ask questions and and some
of the things that we can think about I
say are pretty broad we know the the
breadth of software engineering but
there are other things like you know
what's the relevance of icse what's
relevance of conferences and published
papers you know so so once you content
to think about not only what these
speakers are going to present today but
but also some some other questions that
you think are relevant to this topic so
today we're very pleased to have some
some great panelists and I'll introduce
them up here front first of all there's
no griswold San Diego then we have Jim
laris our senior researchers we have
Laurey Williams from North Carolina
State you have John Pincus and other
senior researcher here at Microsoft
Research so the order of presentations
will be Bill and then Jim lares bought
up by Lori and then by John and we will
entertain questions at the very end so
then again welcome bill all right thanks
a lot John I think John and Microsoft
for inviting me out for all you guys
coming today so what I wanted to talk
about is a little bit of my experience
and attempting to be successful in
software engineering research kind of at
a hike conceptual level and my approach
to being successful has been to avoid
the obvious failures if you will the
pitfalls and so I'm going to tell you
about some of those pitfalls so maybe
you can avoid them too and making let
Laurie later take this down another
level
so first let's you know we're talking
about software engineering today but
there's a couple of general parameters
that apply to all CS reach researchers I
think one is that funding at NSF and
DARPA are at an all-time low and this is
really suggesting you know we have to
rethink the way we do research because
the funding available may be changing
we're going to get that funding from
different sources or we're going to just
do less or we're going to go back to
doing you know pure theory you know all
good questions and the second issue
again we're all familiar with is the
short promotion cycles we have an
academia and how that forces us to some
extent into low risk projects which of
course are often low impact projects and
that's the kind of failure in itself
we're looking for high impact in our
research of course so well with that
front you know with that in mind what's
unique to software engineering research
well I think of software engineering
research as being a study of the
effective creation of software and
there's a focus and it's not really a
focus it's really quite broad a focus on
artifacts that is programs the processes
that create them and the tools that
assist in the creation of artifacts
within those processes there's a lot
going on in this area but what's common
is that there's an inherent practicality
to the endeavor right it's about issues
of scale it's about real programmers and
schedules and ultimately about
cost-benefit you have to say I we spent
this much money or time or whatever
building this and how much value do we
derive from in terms of contributions to
society or profit or whatever and so
that's really sort of the bottom of
software engineering research okay so
you know I felt I didn't really have the
the answer to this so I wrote to a bunch
of my colleagues and a few of them
thankfully replied to me and said what
they thought about this topic so David
rosenblum talked about the lack of
connection that many academic
researchers have to real problems and
that they can get stuck in research at
ease improving each other's research
results but never really getting back to
connecting that to reality if you will
or some eventual past a reality of
course there's more theoretical unless
theoretical more practical research but
for some connection to reality over some
period of time
and Kevin Sullivan talked about sort of
from a economic risk portfolio
perspective talked about putting all
your eggs in one basket as being a
failure mode and Daniel Jackson talked
about the advice the butler Lampson gave
him which is have one high-risk project
and one low-risk project of course Nora
high-risk was probably high impact low
risk is probably low impact and if the
high risk project started to pay off to
kill off the low impact project so
that's kind of a portfolio management
technique Kevin Sullivan Elsa mentioned
this idea failing fast which is to say
that if your project is going to fail
find out early kill it off and move your
resources on to the next project okay
excellent excellent advice Daniel
Jackson spoke to the failure that he had
which is the belief that all real
systems have real research problems in
them and this may be true but there they
may not be accessible that is the
artifacts are too big and too
complicated in the groups that are
developing them are simply too busy and
this is what he faced with air traffic
control system and he had to move on to
another project after wasting a
considerable amount of effort and in a
related vein Daniel talked about the
difficulty of finding exemplars which to
him means small problems that capture
the essence of real problems and if you
can work on exemplars instead of real
systems you can be very effective in
your research because you're not dealing
with all of the complexities just the
essential ones and so you can have high
impact at low cost but excited this is a
really difficult thing to do okay with
these really nice thoughts in mind I'm
gonna talk about what some of my
problems have been over the last several
years and how I address them so one of
my big problems has been attracting
strong students students coming out of
undergraduate programs typically like
good training and software engineering
research they have a lack of
appreciation for what software
engineering is about and so they lack
good intuition or motivation I've mostly
been very successful in recruiting
student recruiting students who've been
an industry for a while because they
have that appreciation of some of that
training there's all I've also had real
problems in achieving experimental
validity which in a nutshell is what you
might call realism with experimental
controls okay so I tried doing research
inside saic and that was awful because
of the politics and they chain
their direction every day and you move
that stuff to your lab and then you lose
a lot of the realism and that's a very
difficult trade-off to manage and in
this research to name and third is main
to the problem is maintained an
acceptable pace of research just your
building stuff you're measuring it and
then your measure analyzing all the
stuff you've measured it just takes an
enormous amount of time so the work is
very slow and that makes that your risk
in your portfolio look really high okay
so I thought about this for a while and
I realized gee this is all about scale
right I'm trying to solve a scale
problem software engineering is
principally a scale problem and darn it
if to solve scale problems you need
scale right PhD bound college grads
don't appreciate scale they've been
taking 10 to 15 week courses for four
years it's all about the short term
right it's hard to replicate scale in a
research laboratory setting it's hard to
control it in the industry setting and
addressing scale requires a large
research effort you just can't do it by
yourself in your office you know you
really got to build up a group and that
means more students more time or money
and we've already noted that that we
have a problem there okay and of course
is going to be especially hard on young
professors because they don't have
contacts and the students and money etc
so this is very I think is a very
challenging environment to do research
so what are some of the things that I
did to solve these problems well for
attracting students like I got into the
area Hugh Vic was computing and I
started doing software engineering
research in that area and that's been
somewhat successful they're very
difficult that have certainly attracted
a much broader pool of students and in
achieving experimental validity a key
thing that no one would overlook here is
the importance of collaborating with
people in industry and to use state
grant programs like you see micro to get
some leverage out of that and it's been
very effective for me the third is to
use open artifacts and tools and by open
I mean that you can plug in your
analysis or whatever you've done into a
real tool that people are using and
there's also openness in terms of source
code and whatnot and that's another way
to kind of ramp up to the the valid
level more quickly than you might
normally be able to and for an
acceptable pace of research again
collaborating is a huge win not only
because you have more hands but they're
more specialized hands and so they bring
special talents to the table and to
build a hierarchical team of PhD
students master students and
undergraduates so that they can help
each other and that also prepares the
PhD students for a life in academia and
lastly I would recommend cultivating
secret weapons so this is kind of my
version of by don't build right which is
once you've built something try to use
it for a while don't just throw it away
and move on to the next thing so you
might have a tool or a research method
or you know some artifact that you've
worked on for a long time and and those
begin this can really accelerate your
productivity okay so to get a little
outside of the box here a couple of
laughs comments one is I think that
something that I've been impressed by
what other people have done and I feel
like I've been less successful isn't
asking the right questions the idea here
is that a small project needn't have
small impact and one way to do this is
to think about what parts things do I
have to build or what parts do I have to
measure to get the research question I
want to address rather than just
building and building and building in
and say well now what's the question
let's see if we can do an experience
report right and lastly I something I've
been much more successful at because I
fail a lot is making lemonade which is
looking at my own failures for research
ideas and you know suppose you're
building a bug finding tool and it's not
finding enough bugs may be found more
than the other guys but you know you're
expecting much better well why doesn't
the tool find more bugs that could
actually lead to really deep insights
about the phenomenon of construction and
execution of software artifacts it's
actually more important than the tool
itself and so there's a lot of ending a
lot of rich fodder there as well so
that's all I had to say and
hand it over to Jim is this working good
I don't have slides the Microsoft people
don't have slides and the spit in this
panel so I that is a very nice talk bill
I'm going to give you a totally
different perspective because I've taken
a very different course than bill IE was
professor for eight years the university
of wisconsin and I came to Microsoft
eight years ago for a year's sabbatical
and I haven't left my cassatt and the
reason actually has a lot to do with
this panel is that I came here to see
how the real world worked I didn't
necessarily really want to see it that
close up so i went to microsoft research
and I figured I could you know see a lot
about software development inside
Microsoft and what I saw is this amazing
opportunity that really wasn't being
looked at by anybody else that you know
the Microsoft developers had these huge
problems in terms of software
development problems of scale problems
of complexity problems of errors and the
code you name it they're just a rich
source of problems and I looked in the
university and I didn't see very many
people actually looking at these real
and one of the one of the things that
made me decide to stay here is that I
thought about this and I thought you
know I could go back to Wisconsin I
could be a professor and I certainly
have a lot more ideas about what I would
do with myself and my graduate students
when I got back but then I asked whether
it was going to be possible to actually
do the kind of research that would
really make an impact on these problems
in a university and my conclusion was no
and I think it actually goes to the
point of this panel discussion so you
know one of the issues that would seem
to me to be the most pressing is
software was developed by professional
programmers in companies and not just
microsoft in a fundamentally different
way than students in universities
develop software so you know I don't
know that those of you who knew me at
Wisconsin to that I wrote a lot of
software at Wisconsin and it was very
widely used suffer but it was academic
software which means that
it's tiny in comparison to what people
build here it's simple in comparison to
what people build here you know any
other commercially successful company
and this is two projects and
universities is that they're typically
developed by one or two or three
graduate students over a very short
amount of time they're only brought out
in a small number of versions and then
they basically died away or they get
they go into the sort of place where
they're no longer maintained it's rare
that a project actually persists for a
long period of time and is supported by
large numbers of people and the question
is how do you actually do research with
people who have no experience in terms
of doing commercial software development
hundred bill said you get people who
went to industry and came back that's
certainly a good way of doing it because
they're much more aware of the actual
constraints but now my experience was
that there weren't all that many people
who fit in that category now maybe after
the.com boom and bust there are more
people who had that experience but there
wasn't when I left the university so
that that's one thing is that the people
who were in universities really didn't
do software development the way in which
commercial software was developed and
didn't have any experience doing
software development that way second
problem was there was no software
available to study in universities that
was anywhere comparable to the software
that commercial companies developed I
think this is less true now because of
the open source community but I'll get
back to that in a minute so yeah this is
this is a serious problem you know in a
university what are you going to study
well you could sort of write the
software yourself and then study it but
that has some pretty serious
experimental problems particularly if
you don't believe the people are writing
the software are the same as the people
who would be writing it in the
commercial environment and if you don't
write the software yourself what do you
get well you know when I was in
University we had the spec benchmarks
tiny programs on a commercial scale 10
20,000 line programs sort of commercial
cores not really application no GUI
nothing it made them particularly
interesting or challenging just so the
issue then is what's the what's the gist
for it well you know you could go
and try to collaborate with a company
and you could try to get access to their
source code and you could try to sort of
do work but those are you in the room
who've tried that know that that's very
difficult is the companies don't tend to
want to have Outsiders look at their
source code you're an outsider you're
not part of the process you don't really
have the same kind of access you're
doing a company and your graduate
students probably don't either and
they're been examples of this being
successfully applied but there are few
and far between so i said i sended say
something about open source so i think
open source has changed the equation a
little bit there are certainly large
amounts of open source software out
there and by large I mean commercially
equivalent applications so i would say
something like linux waltz considerably
smaller than windows still is equivalent
to the other UNIX is in terms of size
and complexity and is probably
comparable to windows in those
dimensions to and there are other things
open office from the Mozilla browser and
things like that which are certainly
equivalent to their commercial all
versions of the software there are a
couple of problems I think though one of
which is that the development process
for open-source software is different
than the development process for
commercial software and you can argue
whether this is a good or a bad thing
and I think it's an interesting debate
but you know from somebody observing it
and having been part of the open source
community for a while before I came here
the process is quite different than the
way in which commercial software is
developed and so the conclusions you
draw for an open source software don't
necessarily apply to software inside the
university the second problem I've seen
is that very few people have ever taken
advantage of this ability this large
amount of software I see very very few
real studies of open-source software
probably the most successful person
unaware of his Dawson Tingler who
actually was able to go in and do non
trivial things to the Linux kernel both
in terms of building tools finding bugs
and doing sort of interesting innovative
work and then and the reason that I
think he was successful is first of all
he's a great hacker and it wasn't
uncomfortable with 3 million lines of
code
but second of all he actually was from
the operating systems community and so
understood the domain of the application
in the first place and when I see a lot
of going on is people saying well you
know I want my graduate students to work
on this large piece of code but you know
they don't know where to get started on
3 million lines of code they don't
really understand the domain of it they
really are not equivalent to the people
who are writing it and so this isn't
this is a challenging problem for I
think people who want to use the open
source software effectively is that you
need a large amount of leverage to
actually take advantage of it's not
enough that it's just out there on the
web but you actually have to be able to
make effective use of it then the third
problem I saw is that there was not a
clear path for results to flop flow from
the universities back into companies and
I think that this is still an immense
problem is that most of the software
engineering literature seems to be
written for other practitioners of the
software engineering rather than for
people who actually do software
engineering or software construction for
a living if you look at what people who
dis offer for a living are aware of it's
not what's published in I Tripoli
transactions on software it's what comes
out of you know various fats to be quite
honest things like extreme programming
which may have some very good ideas
behind it but that's what most people
think of as being useful to them for
day-to-day because it actually is not so
much concerned with experimental
validity or anything like that but is
actually concerned with trying to solve
the problems that people see in their
day-to-day life and I think that this is
an immense disconnect between the
software engineering community and the
people who do software engineering and
you know one of the things that's been
possible inside Microsoft is that we're
very much in contact with the people who
do software development we talked to
them we don't necessarily always see eye
to eye with them but there is a much
clearer path for technology transfer
between Microsoft Research and the
various parts of the company and I think
it's actually been very very successful
because there isn't this huge gap we
haven't been able to make you know huge
fundamental changes like to get people
to use formal methods or anything like
that but you know we
have been able to change the way in
which Microsoft developed software since
I came here it's really an immense
difference in eight years in terms of
Microsoft's acceptance of formal tools
Microsoft's use of tools Microsoft's
belief the tools are actually going to
make a difference in terms of software
development and software quality and
I've seen that and I think that that was
only possible because the people who did
it in particular people like John we're
with inside Microsoft and seen as part
of the same company not people on the
outside writing papers for other people
on the outside and so you know I point
these all out not necessarily it's
criticisms of the software engineering
community but really as sort of my
perception of why you have a very
difficult task if you want to do
research in this area you're trying to
study something that's very different
from the environment in which you're in
and then you're trying to get your
results to go out to a large number of
people who are working in a very
different world so that's
I'm Lori Williams is this working now
and I'm an assistant professor at North
Carolina State University and actually
I'm hoping that my talk leads well off
of the last two talks and what I'll be
talking about is using industry as case
studies in sulfur engineering research
and doing it from universities as a
means for being a successful researcher
and my research group we to look at
software process testing reliability and
security and we call ourselves the
software engineering real search group
because ultimately as a PhD student
graduates they work with real engineers
on real projects and the purpose is to
have real impact in the industry as
opposed to just influencing other
researchers and so what I'll be talking
about today in my 10 minutes were as
long as we said there's all that you
know that's it's a broad range of things
we if you can talk about with it but
that's what I chose to talk about in my
10 minutes of fame and so what I'll
start out with there's lots of different
kinds of empirical studies that can be
done with sulfur engineering research
and what kind of studies that you do
really depends on the maturity of the
technology and so what I have here is a
stages of software technology maturation
that was developed by Sam red wine and
Bill riddle back 20 years ago and it
starts out with basic research and ends
with popularization we're a technology
is actually into the practitioner
mainstream and in order to advance from
one stage of another you need to prove
to someone whether it be yourself or
someone else that you did a good thing
and so the validation step is an
important step but where you are in the
Federation process depends on what you
should be doing for example the first
four steps for the most part you're
trying to influence other researchers
wet war yourself so you're trying to
influence the state of the art and other
researchers and so the kinds of studies
you might do would be simulations toy
examples student projects experiments
where when you get to the last two steps
you're trying to influence the state of
the practice and
practice and practitioners and that's
really the area that I'll be talking
about in my talk today and so this is
the area where industrial case studies
are really important I'm Sam a red wine
and Bill riddle talk about these last
two phases and talk about that the need
for good case studies to influence
practitioners practitioners will adopt a
new technology if people like themselves
have adopted the technology and been
successful at it so it's important to
get stories of people being successful
out so that other practitioners will use
the technique and so one of the first
examples of case study research that we
did was focus on extreme programming we
wanted to look at whether extreme
programming did help organizations be
more successful and we wanted to do some
case studies and so the first thing we
did was look at the literature to find
out what was going on with extreme
programming and as we said a lot of
things that we saw were qualitative case
study experience reports from
organizations that used it that didn't
have very many quantitative measures
there were some studies done by
academics but every study measured
something different and so what we
wanted to do is get a measurement
framework so that we can establish a
base an evidentiary basis of extreme
programming and so we developed a a
framework which we call for extreme
programming the extreme programming
evaluation framework which has three
parts to it contacts factors adherence
metrics and outcome measures and I'll
give you an example of a case study you
know I'll talk about what each one of
them are we did develop the case study
framework for extreme programming the
rational unified process the team
software process and then most recently
I'm extreme programming 2 was released
towards the end of last year which has a
lot of differences and you can see with
all of those case studies we we ran them
with different people at different
companies we ran case studies so we we
have been working with organizations
just to clarify this down here this put
microsoft down here that's part of the
template that's not saying that we did a
case study with with microsoft and
extreme programming to
although we would be happy to do that so
here's an example that we did with Sabre
Airlines and this is context factor so
context factors is trying to say to
someone who digests the egg case study
is this organization like mine so if you
have a small co-located team that the
case study was done on if you have a
large distributed team the case studies
probably irrelevant to you so it's
trying to capture what is this team like
what is this project like will this be
relevant to me we have we have lots of
measures sees this is a high level
overview of a sabre case study which
there was 18 months for free free XP
versus sustained use of XP this was a
small co-located team working on a GUI
environment down at the bottom is a
graphical view of the context factors 5
and 5 of what are considered the most
important factors which is how skilled
are the people to the requirements
change what's the culture of the people
the size of the team and the criticality
of a defect in the software those five
factors were deemed by Barry Bane to be
important factors that would say is this
team amenable to an agile methodology or
or not and for the most part this team
is a small collocated team and extreme
programming should work well for it
another thing that we do which hasn't
been much before is adherence so did the
team actually use extreme programming a
lot of teams might say I do extreme
programming but when you start to say
well do use pear programming well no we
do extreme programming but just not pair
programming well do you do the testing
no no we don't do that but the rest of
it we do and so if you peel away you
need to find out exactly what are they
doing really in any technology that you
study so we measure adherence metrics
and then the last of the outcome
measures which are business related
results such as productivity quality
customer satisfaction I'm around and so
you know again as using industrial case
studies as being a way of having
successful research from a university
there's some pros and cons to using
industrial case studies first of all a
good thing is a salience check
so it and bill talked about this in the
beginning is tying it back to a real
problem and so if you're trying to do
something and you can't get any industry
to work with you then maybe your problem
isn't a real problem and so the ability
to get a partner kind of tells you
whether you have a salient research
problem or not even with that finding
partners can be difficult obtaining the
measures can be difficult and it can
take a long time to run a case study you
need to have a whole release of a
product and you need to be out in the
field so it takes a quite a bit of time
as far as acceptance of research results
in general with you know software
engineering research community they
enjoy reading papers related to industry
as opposed to student experiments
however a case study is a N equals one
experiment in some view and so with that
sometimes people don't appreciate them
quite as much industrial case studies
support and movement towards evidence
based software engineering which is
building up a base to allow
practitioners to base their decisions on
research results and finally you know
the main motivating factor is to have an
impact on industrial practice
and so since I'm the only person on the
panel who has the advantage of never
having actually practiced suffer
engineering in a university context it's
natural that I should go last some of
the points I was going to make I think
Laurie get some really good examples
from from the standpoint of being in
Microsoft Research and trying to bridge
the gap between research and
practitioners one of the things that's
incredibly important is to understand
whether ideas are likely to be relevant
in practice for the problems that we
face at our company and there can be
good ideas that are irrelevant there can
be ideas that are as yet unproven there
can be bad ideas and in general we have
a lot more ideas just ourselves than we
can actually investigate and get the
product groups are our partners who are
actually doing the development to
investigate so there's a very high
burden of proof as we're looking at
these things we want some some strong
evidence that it's likely to be worth
pursuing so you know if there's large
potential payoff and its early stages
well okay we need we need evidence that
there's likely to be large external pay
off beyond more than just the it's
possible and the kinds of breakdowns
that Laurie talked about these very
detailed breakdowns of understanding the
contexts understanding the the specific
experiments or case studies that have
been run whether they're natural
experiments or constructed experiments
understanding that and getting a deep
understanding of how mature this
research really is is very crucial for
from our perspective on understanding is
this an area that is likely to be of
interest to other people and I think the
same is true in in in situations where
you're directly speaking to the
practitioners where there's not this
this mediating organization there i
think the burden is going to be even
higher to convince them that this idea
is better than the ideas they have
themselves that they can't work at that
they don't have the time to work on and
this is this is a huge issue I think in
the field of software engineering today
that the time it takes to do these kinds
of detailed analyses is not rewarded by
the prestige of the publications let
alone the number
publications that you can come out with
this is something that all i can do is
express sympathy but observe as an
outsider that there needs to be some way
of using alternate publication methods
of working within the we think the whole
promotion process so that there's more
incentive if the goal is to actually
make an impact in this way particularly
with the late stage research that there
actually is more incentive and work I'd
settle for there being less disincentive
to do this kind of work but I actually
like to turn things around and look at
an area where I think academia has a
huge advantage over industry in terms of
software research and that's that fact
that increasingly kinds of problems that
we face and software engineering are
really cross-disciplinary they're not
inherently only computer science
problems I think agile programming is a
really good example of this in general
that if you look at a lot of the
techniques to the extent that they work
or don't work it's not as a
manifestation of classic computer
science principles is very important
social aspects going on here involving
the sociology the other psychology of
the programming teams I think as we look
at the more general problem of not just
how do we construct software but what
cuts software are reconstructing is it
the right software for its uses in
context you start to come to the realms
where things like a cognitive science
and again sociology economics etc are
become incredibly important factors in
all of these and even a place like
Microsoft Research which has a
relatively large research department is
woefully under invested in these non
computer science areas when compared to
a typical University and so I think that
that the real opportunity or a set of
real opportunities for academic research
is is really broadening this notion of
what goes into software engineering so
that it's being done in conjunction with
in these other lenses and you're not
it's not going to be easy to get closer
to the code
canon in a industrial setting as Jim
points out with open source you can
approximate that as Laurie points out by
partnering with industry again you can
get approximate us closer to code so
there's never going to be an inherent
advantage there it's important to take
this this dramatically different
perspective I think so although this is
a a short talk I really think that's the
key towards rethinking these problems
okay need to find where's my runner here
with the microphone he's not here okay
well I'll do it okay yes
there has been emphasis on successful
software engineering research but the
specific topics of doing in software
engineering on which research can be
done has not been emphasized too much
and for example if I am from India and
we have around five billion dollar
service industry which in a way day in
and day out they are developing various
kinds of small applications to very
large applications for most of the day
to day activities there are different
groups of software engineers spread
around geographically distant areas and
there are various issues that have come
up in developing large products and
delivering it on time and making profit
reusability artifacts and various other
issues and so I would like to see some
light on what kind of issues you think
would be useful there
well I mean I think this is a classic
example of something that's really going
to be amenable to an interdisciplinary
approach what are the you for example in
this particular scenario where people
it's in many ways it's the economics
which are driving this what are the
different cam approaches that you want
to take to reusable software and the
value of reusability there are
traditional notions for what it means to
be for software to be reusable and the
ways in which it's reused are those just
optimized for the the old fashioned
within a single corporation for
particular uses can we broaden these
notions perhaps with different metrics
and again bringing in the sort of more
the different analytical techniques that
you get from these social sciences might
point to a way towards different
approaches for adopting these problems
attacking these problems that's that's
actually a very good question something
we should have probably addressed in our
in our in our introductory remarks I
have a couple of ideas I mean to me if I
look around this or the most pressing
need is the ability to actually write
down specifications and designs for
software in a way in which the
practitioner is not just you know
experts in a small area can actually use
these in their day-to-day life so you
know particularly when you talk about
software development over a wide area or
in different countries the ability to
actually write down in advance and to do
some analysis and design to make sure
that it works before you go off and
build it and before you have complicated
contractual relationships is extremely
important and it's an extremely
underserved area in the field I mean
it's obviously been around for a long
time but it's underserved in the sense i
don't think that there are any solutions
that are widely acceptable or you know
even widely known and i think that there
would be an excellent area for people to
focus in on because i don't see a lot of
that work going on anywhere in industry
or in academia
I would like to bring the focus from
software engineering research to
software engineering teaching so for
example are you what she mentioned about
building case studies so that you will
be able to bring out certain issues in a
very convincing fashion that's a very
good effort let's see you know software
engineering is traditionally been a very
boring subject for the undergraduate
students who haven't seen the real world
in the real software development etc and
then in the classroom you're going to
tell them about you know this is how you
should do and then these are the
millions of lines of code and you need
to use the configuration control
management and all that okay yeah yeah
that's all good but they're not really
seeing what you really mean and why they
need to really practice oft where
engineering whatever the processes or
aspects in the when you're teaching
software engineering so typically this
is the course that is appreciated after
they come back to school and tell them
liquid that time I didn't appreciate now
I understand what you meant by that we
connect an experiment last year I was
teaching software engineering course at
iiit hyderabad india what we did is we
did an extreme step of conducting all
the classes using just the case studies
these are not the case studies that you
are mentioning about but these are the
teaching case studies like Howard
business school style case studies so we
brought we worked with industry like
services industry include on also
Microsoft and then actually brought a
problem the real problem to the
classroom along with the real managers
who kind of kind of manage that project
and then it kind of it was really very
well appreciated by the students so like
this is something maybe no one way of
changing the perception of the subject
so do I mean I would like to see your
comments or any reactions to this
I guess I mean the only one comment I'll
make it sounds great and I would
encourage you to try it if these case
studies are publishable so that others
can use them too that'd be fabulous but
I guess you're saying that you had real
case studies from your local area and
you actually brought the managers of
those case studies into the classroom
yeah which is even better but I think it
would be great to have just like Harvard
Business Review has that a whole
collection of of cases that can be used
with so for engineering students to
present those kinds of classical
large-scale problems so all I could say
is that's great okay we have a question
back here actually could I just speak to
that a little bit a little bit more so I
think this relates to the the training
and appreciation thing that I brought up
earlier and why I want to speak to it
and we've talked earlier about you know
students going off to industry coming
back and they have the training in the
appreciation but I should be a little
bit careful that there's research
methods and software engineering that
I'm looking for training in as well as
appreciation for the problems and
software engineering and I want to do
couple them a little bit because the
research methods are very different than
developer methods especially for the
stuff that Lori just presented you don't
have to write a line of code to do her
experiments right and so you know other
disciplines to figure this out you know
physicists use astronomy to inspire
students you know mechanical civil
engineers use you know beautiful bridge
designs and things like that and
computer science little tough because a
lot of the phenomena of computing are
fairly abstract you have to get into it
for a while before you appreciate it but
we do have our you know graphics and
video games and beautiful visualizations
and spinning atoms in space and things
and I think you know there's a little
bit of a bait and switch you know you
you see the beautiful constellations
then you go study physics and you know
you're you're reading you know X ray you
know traces on sheets for the next 40
years you know sitting in the dark and
it's like wait that's not what got me
into this in the first place and you
know so you know it's not like you I
mean think of it this way just as a does
a future physicist have to become an
atom to appreciate physics well why
should a computer science or software
engineering researcher have to become a
practitioner to appreciate appreciate
the development of software
something a little you know I think we
have to be a little bit careful here and
say no I'm not a software engineer I'm a
software engineering research it would
be inappropriate set but I do have you
know certain skills and research methods
and that's what you know we should
inspire developer appreciation but we
don't want to turn all of our all the
researchers and developers that's too
expensive it's one way to do it but it's
not the only way I mean with with all
due respect I some would disagree i'd
say that that the software engineering
researcher not having a grounding on
what software engineering is in practice
is sort of like a sociologists not not
living in any society that or
psychologists not being a thinking
person or being self aware that that
we're not studying in software
engineering we're not studying the
fundamental rules of the known universe
we're studying these complex social
systems and and you have to have some
experience of understanding the social
systems in order to effectively be able
to study them even if it's not the
specific system you're studying and
certainly agree so I certainly grant you
that but a society of developers is a
culture and a society in fact a lot of
the most insightful methods in software
engineering research today our
anthropological methods and those blend
tremendous insights because the social
networks to develop and the customs that
develop it it all works out and there is
a deep technical component that needs to
be understood but but you know that said
I mean again I'm going to come back and
say yes i'm a member and i was an
anthropologist a member of some society
but you know that society over there
just really is seemed so divorced for
mining it these people these people do
research so the question is what
connections do you need and i think that
you know the the experience that one
develops over time as a researcher and
as a developer me because we all have
done software development in teams right
just not necessarily commercial but
that's a different again it's one
culture to another so i think you know
it has the potential workout not saying
no no researcher should do this
the split 50-50 I mean so you know what
you know Jim said he stayed here you
know for these reasons but he's still
not a commercial software developer
right he's still basically you know
academic researcher sitting a lot closer
to the developers than he was before and
I think he's being pretty successful I
want to tell you as quickly as I can
about the experience of an academic
scientist shifting in the other
direction working in the business world
so I took a job for a year as a CTO of a
small software company that a friend of
mine owned that has development office
is ringing the planet Dresden London
Edmonton Kuala Lumpur and Arbor
Sacramento Sydney and Belo Horizonte in
Brazil it was an interesting exercise
and I can confirm some of the things
that I've heard you say the first point
is that the key problem I see as a
researcher is developing ways to
communicate at different levels of
granularity so Jim spoke directly to
this we don't have sufficiently good
tools to communicate and choose our
levels of communication to give you an
example is that trusted developers and
team leaders working from Kuala Lumpur
to Dresden can be effective in
developing a complex piece of code that
i cannot outsourced to a team in india
because i can't manage the level of
abstraction and the in the communication
with that said leadership in how to
communicate and how to communicate
cross-culturally within a single company
is also essential speaks to the antrum
anthropology study so there are some
things that we've done we had an
anthropology student do a master's
degree study and cross-cultural software
engineering development that can make
available to people if you're interested
so but the key that I found as a
researcher is going back and forth that
we simply don't have sufficient tools to
manage the granularity of abstraction
Thanks from Indiana University my
experience has been actually somewhat
frustrating I guess I'll share it with
you and you guys comment on it I grew up
in the database world my client
undergraduate and graduate work and so
forth but I moved to computational
biology and bioinformatics and what I've
discovered is while we were taught that
lots of these methods are the only way
to do things and this is how to get
projects done what we've discovered
through several years now is that most
of the things that we were taught don't
seem to work in this area I mean there's
many obvious reasons one is that the
scientists don't really have work at a
company it's kind of a loose
confederation of who's doing what work
and what's what's important I'm curious
how do we make inroads in these sciences
and we've done a poor job my feel is
right now in employing successful
software engineering practices what what
might we do and and I would say from a
academic standpoint even submitting
research in terms of what counts as as
impact you know we face this sort of two
edged sword the biologists don't really
care if we get something running in a
nice time complexity on the other hand
the database people would say well look
it's all been figured out I don't care
that you can model stuff pretty
successfully so I'd like some comments
so let me take that out I don't know if
you're familiar with the work that Jim
Gray has done yeah so for those of you
not familiar Jim Gray is at Microsoft
Research in the Bay Area and he's done a
lot of work with the Astronomy community
after physics community and in basically
he's a extremely well-known database
researcher who has come on and basically
said to this community you know you have
a tremendous amount of data you're
storing it in flat files you're missing
you know all of what's been learned in
databases for the last 30 years and he's
actually gone and made it real by going
and working with the people who have the
data and showing them if they put it
into a relational database that things
that take you know pages and pages of
Perl script can be done in the single
sequel correct great
I think that that's the way in which you
answer one of your questions which is
how do you have impact on the scientific
community you basically have to show
them that the products of computer
science and software engineering are
better than the way in which they've
done things and you have to be willing
to sort of persist in spite of the fact
that they see you as equivalent to the
guy who does the plumbing for their lab
but you know I think that if there
really are advantages then people will
eventually come around to see it and you
know hopefully there are advantages in
terms of the way in which we do things
sometimes it's difficult to I just want
to add that you know the tech transfer
process is traditionally very slow and
they say 20 to 25 years and you can
accelerate that by you know some of the
things that Jim just described although
I guess relational databases are about
25 years old so you're right right
exactly you know they're the whole
reason the supercomputers exist at the
universities is to accelerate this
process as well but if you look at the
way software testing is done today if
you look at you know the Ides that we
use the you know the software
development methods everything all of
those are 25 year derivatives out of out
of academic research and you just have
to be patient Jim earlier talked about
you know software process you know XP he
mentioned that you know when I first saw
XP I was like oh and this works because
of this and this works because that's
and that thing that's wrong there and
then boom you know three years later
it's gone because you know somebody
figured out it didn't work and so you
know although you don't necessarily see
the direct path I think if you go back
and look you could actually find that
you know these these methods and tools
you know do come out of the academic
community the best method of
dissemination you know we find it from
universities is students they take the
ideas out because people are too busy to
read and when things get you know one
person reads an article here and rewrite
sit there and amorous you know
digestible form stuff gets lost I mean
I'm amazed you know I do interviews and
I read these things I'm like wow what
happened my word
so you know there's no there's no
substitute for somebody being there and
that we really think of students as the
ultimate dissemination tool software
engineering research is obviously
focusing up to a certain degree on
process production of quality software
etc that's an important thing but I
think it gives an incremental refinement
or improvement the question is what is
on the other side the disruptive
technologies what do you think what are
those sounds like a question for Bill
Gates not us it's it's it's a very good
question I mean you know one of the
things that was very frustrating is that
for a long time here at research we were
building tools to find defects and
software and we built a number of
different tools in my group some of
which are extremely well known in the
academic community others of which are
actually employed in Microsoft products
and they're effective at finding defects
and software but at some point you
basically say this is a very frustrating
wait to go about this you know if the
goal is to produce better software then
finding the mistakes after people have
made them is maybe not the most direct
path to producing better software and
then you start asking the question are
there ways to reduce better software
which you know you start try to more
directly produce the software and I
think that approaching it from that way
would be very disruptive I mean you know
if you go back 20 30 years in computer
science people were much more interested
in these bigger picture more aggressive
solutions to the problems you can find
lots of conferences about programming
languages for better software
programming languages to reduce defects
and software you don't see that anymore
instead you see people focused on much
more narrow technical solutions to
problems but for the most part these
these smaller incremental solutions are
not going to lead to huge major changes
and so
you know you see a lot of the benefit in
the inertia are actually shifting to
industry rather than research because
perhaps because of the funding situation
become apt because of the 10-year cycle
people are less willing to sort of go
out and take aggressive measures and in
fact if they do I think they have
trouble finding places to publish them
that are academically established and
you know I don't have a good answer to
that if I did we would be doing it but I
think you have to go and be much more
aggressive you know we started a project
inside research called singularity which
basically said what would software look
like if the goal was to produce software
that was more reliable and forget about
performance and so we're doing things
like writing the entire operating system
in safe code in the equivalent of Java C
sharp and doing things like that and
bring in tools very early in the process
and sort of changing the software
architecture to try to provide more
isolation between parts of the system so
things like that which I think are very
difficult to do on a small scale and
very difficult to do in a university but
are much more likely to lead to big
changes where you catch the errors
earlier you prevent the errors in the
first place or mitigate the consequences
of the eris as opposed to going and
trying to find defects and software I
think one of the things that we've heard
several different times here which is a
huge source of these potentially
disruptive areas is things focused on
communications both within the team but
also with users and requirements is in
some sense a communication problem it's
not clear to me it's ever really been
tackled as a communications problem and
this is actually an area where the other
the different pneus of open-source
development environments and their
quirkiness and they're distributed
nature and the fact that everybody's
doing their own thing is actually a
virtue from the standpoint of
understanding some of these
communications issues that solutions for
their will actually apply into in more
constrained environments as well so I
think that's an interim says if we had
more concrete ideas what would be off
working on them right now instead of
said I got this panel the other thing
that I'd like to highlight is is it is
it a time to possibly start rethinking
architecture more oriented around grace
degradation particularly with the
respect to both security and privacy the
intrusion tolerant computing field has
has some aspects of this are there other
approaches that's something where as Jim
points out we can we can be giving up
some performance we can posit things
like safe languages for the component
construction are there new ways of
tackling that that would possibly let us
get at the two things one real world
security guarantees I mean security
guarantees of the kinds that people has
in users actually care about and then to
does this give a different way of
looking at the composability problem
which is still essentially an unsolved
problem in the general case actually had
one thing to what gym just said because
I actually had a very similar thought
about the reaction to all this work in
bug detection in that it seems you know
oh gosh if we could just have found
those bugs in the first place and of
course we know we can't find them all
and a lot of these techniques find stuff
that you know just who would think the
stuff up anyway and but it's become a
fat almost everyone's doing it right and
it's like okay maybe it's time to move
on in a 22 comments one is that the
strength of the bug detection work is
that it fits into a part of the software
development process that reached
researchers can get in and so it's very
it's very pragmatic in terms of having
real impact but now what I'm starting to
see is people are starting to take stuff
out of that work and sort of push it up
the software development chain so
they're starting to characterize a lot
of what they're doing in terms of types
well once they're types those things can
be concretize din a number of ways and
treated in different ways not to find
bugs but to prevent them and i'm
starting to see several results coming
out now so it's it's you know you think
oh this is a you know we're going down
the wrong path and all of a sudden
people have have you know changed
direction so i think it's very difficult
to look at the the macro environment and
all the activities going on and predict
where it's going to go and how it's
going to work out and one of the one of
the key aspects to successful research
in the modern world is that
you have a community developing things
are a lot of bets down on the table most
don't pay off some do and as a
consequence we all move forward through
some sort of stochastic process that's
economically speaking very successful
even though it looks like a large
investment but I mean on the bug
detection thing on that hole area I
think this is an interesting area in
that it wasn't actually driven by
academic research the the things the
recent flurry and academic research was
actually in response to hug some
commercial bug detection I gave me a
2000 talk talking about the specific
dynamics that had at the time I think
kept some some of the academic work from
having this influence and I think
there's still lessons there to be
learned from other areas as you point
out tracking what's going on in outside
of the research community and then
trying to distill it it's like the work
that's happened after that initial
commercial work is much more impressive
from the research perspective and is
leading to these deeper and more
transformative changes what can be
learned in both directions i think is in
general a good way for fun for
discovering new research areas
but want to appreciate everybody's input
the questions were we're great and I
think are pounded up did a great job
here so thank you very much